this
is portobelli Hill
situated in the Arid Hills of
Southeastern turkey the mound had long
been considered Sacred by the local
Kurdish people on a clear day the view
from the hill was breathtaking providing
just enough height to see all the way to
the distant Horizon irrigated Farms
filling the surrounding Flatlands
but by the mid-20th century
archaeologists had started to realize
that Potbelly Hill was more than just a
good vantage point it was clearly the
remains of an ancient Village abandoned
long ago and covered in Millennia of
dirt
however seeing nothing of exceptional
importance except what was thought to be
grave markers they had moved on
it wasn't until 1994 that another
archaeologist the German Klaus Schmidt
heard of it from the locals
Guided by Farmers to the location of the
Hill he took it upon himself to set
about his own excavation
soon realized that these large
underground Stones were not grave
markers but the tops of huge megaliths
further work revealed a tremendous
complex including towering t-shaped
pillars long arching paths and
concentric circles of imposing stone
walls
but that was not the biggest surprise
for once archaeologists were able to
date the structure its age astounded
them
the complex was over ten thousand years
old
[Music]
Potbelly Hill which in Turkish
translates as quebecally Tepe was
discovered to be one of the oldest
structures ever built by humans
constructed right at the end of the last
ice age and the transition from hunting
and Gathering to a more settled
lifestyle archaeologists still don't
know the true purpose of the site it may
have been a fully functioning Village or
merely a sacred annual Gathering Place
either way Gobekli Tepe was vitally
important to the people who built and
used it
but after they abandoned it again for
his mysterious a reason as to why they
constructed it in the first place it was
lost
thousands of years of human history
hundreds of cultures and dozens of major
civilizations waxed and waned through
the area never considering it more than
an old Hill with some rubbish buried
beneath the surface
Gobekli Tepe serves as a major
Cornerstone for our modern understanding
of the development of human civilization
without it our own past would be that
much more mysterious
it was built only ten thousand years ago
as we push deeper into the past the
story of our Origins becomes even
murkier with fossil fragments scattered
across the globe we can piece together
the general story of human evolution and
development beyond that we understand no
more than the outlines indeed scientists
estimate that we have fossil evidence
for less than one percent of all the
species that have ever lived
that is just life on Earth
we have only just begun to explore the
wider Cosmos without probes and our
telescopes the vast majority of the
universe remains completely unknown and
unmapped what Mysteries await us there
how far back can we push the origins of
not just ourselves and life on Earth
but life in the universe
like Gobekli Tepe what ancient monuments
to life await Us in the depths of
interstellar space
are we among the first generation
or the latest
in a long line
due to the sun's larger space-time
curvature you would get about 67 seconds
less per year on its surface than on
Earth which is disappointing and
sometimes it feels like we don't have
enough time even here this video has
been sponsored by betterhelp and they
are the world's largest therapy service
before better help I personally didn't
have a clue on how to access the right
therapy for me I just didn't have the
time to sort it out whether on Earth or
on the Sun but with better help you can
instantly tap into a network of over 30
000 licensed and experienced therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues to get started you just answer a
few questions about your needs and
preferences and better help can match
you with the right therapist from their
Network you can schedule live sessions
when it's convenient for you with better
help you get the same professionalism
and quality you expect from in-office
therapy but it's all much easier to sort
out and at a more affordable price so
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com forward slash h-o-t-u and
I've also linked them Below in the
description thanks to betterhelp for
supporting educational content on
YouTube
the lone dark rocks stood out a blemish
on the otherwise perfectly smooth
perfectly white ice sheets
it sat there for thousands tens of
thousands of years undisturbed safe for
the rare snowfall
and Roberta score
could not
ignore it
a lab manager from NASA's Johnson Space
Center Roberta had been there in
Antarctica spending the nightless hours
scouring the vast ice fields of that
Frozen continent hunting for rocks
exactly like it
Antarctica is a surprisingly fertile
ground for such fines the Rocks stand
out clearly in contrast to the blinding
White Ice though at first Roberta's rock
found in the Allen Hills Far Western ice
field and so named alh 84001 seemed
unremarkable but in reality it was
anything but for it turned out to not
only be a meteorite having fallen from
space Millennia before but Upon
returning it to Johnson's Space Center
the team discovered that it was no
ordinary meteorite
it was a piece
of Mars
matching the chemical composition of the
Martian surface The Rock must have been
blasted off the red planet millions of
years before during a Titanic Collision
then spending eons wandering The
interplanetary Depths before falling to
Earth where it had rested undisturbed
ever since the team sampled and studied
this Martian Exile then made it
available to The Wider scientific
community and so it was nearly a decade
later when another team led by physicist
David S McKay made a startling
announcement
the unassuming meteorite contained
microscopic features that could not be
the work of mere chemical processes
electron microscopy revealed chain-like
structures that resembled living
organisms found on Earth
this Little Rock contained the
fossilized evidence of life
on Mars
NASA announced the discovery to enormous
Fanfare with even the then president of
the United States Bill Clinton giving an
official statement but after the
celebrations died down and other
scientists got a chance to perform their
own examinations these further studies
immediately cast the original
announcement in doubt Martian chemistry
they said did not have to exactly follow
Earth chemistry and they could concoct a
dozen different scenarios to generate
chain-like features from nothing more
than interesting combinations and
reactions of chemicals fascinating
certainly
but not alive
alh 84001 Remains the only physical
specimen to ever even offer a hope of
identifying life outside the Earth
and the debates surrounding the nature
of its microscopic structures serve as a
potent lesson
could we even identify alien life if it
was staring right at us
[Music]
to identify life we must first Define it
and the scientific literature currently
contains over 200 different definitions
that said a very general classification
scheme is able to Encompass almost all
definitions
and that scheme relies on life having
three distinct properties
One Life must be able to store
information whatever the means life must
encode information about its current
state it must also store information
about its own traits and characteristics
and the information required to generate
various processes
Second Life must be able to catalyze
reactions it must be able to interact
with the environment that surrounds it
responding to it and generating
reactions of its own these reactions
allow life to acquire store and expend
energy they allow life to move they
allow life to react to signals or
threats and lastly these reactions allow
life to grow new structures
and third what separates life from
non-life is the ability to
self-replicate
life must be able to make copies of
itself and these copies must be as
faithful as possible to the original
putting these three things together
allows life
to live
famed physicist Owen Schrodinger was the
first to identify the fundamental
principles of life from a physical point
of view
correctly hypothesizing that the storing
utilization and passing of information
was of Paramount importance the
information stored in life gives it the
instructions it needs to catalyze
reactions and some of those reactions
include the ability for life to
replicate itself life can then go on and
do all the things we normally associate
with living it can move eat protect
itself send and receive sensory signals
and most importantly reproduce
this complete cycle also allows life to
be subject to Natural Selection
pressures from the environment work on
the information passed from one
generation to another selecting some
traits is beneficial for survival and
disregarding others and that in itself
offers another definition of life life
is that which is subject to darwinian
evolution
on present-day Earth we can see a clear
example of this definition
us
we are quite literally living it
we have DNA to store information we have
our proteins that catalyze reactions and
we have RNA that acts as a translation
tool from the information stored in our
DNA to the production of proteins
and to complete the loop our DNA can
issue instructions via RNA to create
proteins that go on to make copies of
our DNA passing on our genetic Legacy
from one generation to another
it's safe to assume that all life in the
universe fulfills this basic definition
if it didn't we would have a very hard
time identifying it as living to put it
simply to search for life we must have a
working definition even if that
definition isn't as broad as it
potentially could be
[Music]
but even on our own planet and with that
definition in hand we run into
interesting edge cases
a virus is alive they store information
and engage in reproduction but they
can't do it alone without a suitable
host
and what about abiogenesis the
appearance of life on the early Earth
at some point a collection of chemical
processes went from non-living to living
and that boundary was probably blurry
the modern Triad of DNA RNA proteins
couldn't have possibly existed in the
first life because if you take one of
those out the cycle of Life cannot
complete
so early life had to be simpler one
hypothesis states that early life was
solely composed of strands of RNA these
earliest forms of life would have been
completely alien to what we have now in
the modern world
some aspects of early life we still find
in common with our own for example early
life still used the liquid water as a
solvent and solvents are critically
important for our understanding of life
this is because the life on Earth uses a
soup of complex molecules to go about
living storing information catalyzing
reactions and so on these molecules need
a place to hang out where they won't get
instantly destroyed and water is stable
enough for exactly those purposes plus
water can bind with many other molecules
it can dissolve the ones you don't want
acting as a form of waste management and
it can be easily blocked allowing you to
build a membrane so that you always have
just the right amount near you
in addition to liquid water early life
also experienced roughly the same
temperatures that we do today
even though the first life may have been
extremophiles like bacteria that can
survive in deep sea hydrothermal vents
that is still within the broad range of
Earth normal early life didn't arise in
the depths of interstellar space or on
the surface of the Sun
early life also used all the same
elements that we're familiar with today
carbon is exceptionally handy as it
combined easily with itself and many
other elements allowing it to form large
strong structures oxygen is great for
participating in chemical reactions
which means it can serve as a useful
tool for storing and later using energy
phosphorus nitrogen and hydrogen also
play important roles especially in the
construction of DNA and RNA
so perhaps early Earth life would not be
so alien after all the same solvent the
same temperatures the same Elemental
building blocks
those microscopic Critters however they
initially emerged would have the same
basic requirements we do water food and
energy
but anything off the Earth is a
completely different story
[Music]
perhaps what happened on our planet is
generic and almost all forms of life in
the universe need the same basic
ingredients water carbon sunlight Etc
or perhaps not after all we only have
one data point to go on
and this was one of the major reasons
why the Martian meteorite was so
fascinating early Mars had liquid water
on its surface and a temperate climate
but Mars also features chemical and
geological processes that are unique to
that planet especially in the billions
of years after its oceans evaporated
and so we must be exceptionally careful
when studying other worlds
thankfully other places in the solar
system give us the opportunity to test
how broad our definitions of life can be
while still being recognizable many of
the outer moons in the solar system like
Enceladus and Europa contain vast oceans
of liquid water but that liquid water is
locked under miles and miles of ice
preventing any sunlight at all from
reaching it not all life on Earth
requires sunlight so could life have
gotten started there in the darkness of
the oceans could a complex food web
evolve driven by organic material
drifting through the icy crusts fed upon
by microscopic organisms to be swept up
by whale-like eyeless Giants
and then there's Titan one of Saturn's
145 moons the second largest moon in the
solar system it was discovered by the
great astronomer Christian highgens in
1655.
that world is cloaked by a dense
atmosphere rich with nitrogen and it is
the only known World other than Earth to
support lakes and rivers on its surface
but at a temperature of minus 180
degrees Celsius these aren't lakes and
rivers of water but of liquid
hydrocarbons like methane
could methane serve as a solvent for an
exotic low temperature form of life
perhaps even multicellular creatures
relying on achingly slow metabolisms
could swim in those Seas
research continues but the only way to
find out for sure would be to go there
the immense atmospheres of the outer
planets may also seem uninhabitable to
us but no one can be sure what strange
physics and exotic chemistry play out in
those depths heat motion complex
compounds all the ingredients are there
buried layer after layer in those
atmospheres
could creatures that never know the feel
of the ground or the taste of water
float majestically in those worlds
and lastly there are all the forms of
life that we can Encompass in our
imaginations
perhaps somewhere in the universe life
uses silicon rather than carbon as a
building block perhaps life doesn't even
need chemicals to store information or
make copies of itself strange Quantum
systems could do the trick or forms of
matter not known to us yet
everything
but to begin our exploration of the
earliest life that could possibly arise
in the universe we will start with the
strictest definition of life that we can
imagine
life that looks like the kind on Earth
that uses water as a solvent in a range
of habitable temperatures using a set of
key Elemental building blocks
[Music]
in 1952 a graduate student at the
University of Chicago named Stanley
Miller developed an experiment to test
the controversial hypothesis developed
by his advisor Nobel prize-winning
chemist Harold Yuri
the experiment was simple Miller took a
flask of water and added a mixture of
methane ammonia and hydrogen he then run
a spark of electricity through the flask
first nothing happened but after a day
the mixture turned faintly pink and
after a week the flask was filled with a
deep red liquid
after adding additional chemicals to
prevent microbial contamination and to
stop the reaction Miller used a
chromatograph to identify what new
molecules had appeared inside the flask
the results astounded him
glycine Alpha alanine Beta alanine
aspartic acid Alpha and aminobutyric
acid
these were amino acids the building
blocks of RNA and DNA the basic
chemistry of life itself
[Music]
Miller's experiment shook the world
prior to his work philosophers
theologians and scientists had only
vague guesses of how life could have
Arisen on the early Earth now the
problem of aviogenesis was planted
firmly in the scientific domain Miller's
experiment had shown how a mixture of
simple common molecules could produce
the basis for the rich organic chemistry
of life
the inputs into the experiment water
methane ammonia and hydrogen are all
amongst the most common molecules in the
universe and are made of carbon oxygen
hydrogen and nitrogen the outputs were
amino acids which are much more varied
and complex Arrangements of those same
basic elements amino acids play a
central foundational role in
Biochemistry our DNA encodes information
for 20 of them and combinations of amino
acids give rise to our protein
structures and all of life on Earth
the experiment had simulated the
hypothesized conditions of the early
Earth a warm mixture of what are known
as Prebiotic molecules the spark had
simulated a lightning strike in a
primordial pool triggering a chemical
transformation that would one day lead
to Life as We Know It
while we still don't understand the path
that led from the Prebiotic early Earth
to a world rich with living beings the
Miller Yuri experiment conclusively
showed that such transitions are
entirely possible
further measurements on sealed vials
from the original experiment revealed
that Miller had created even more amino
acids but without having the capability
to detect them those new amino acids
included variations not used by life on
Earth for whatever reason our planet
having settled on this group of 20 when
many more options are available
the Miller Yuri experiment demonstrates
one Link in the chain of how to create
Life as we know it you need to have a
Prebiotic mixture of elements under the
right conditions
and so to find the earliest life could
arise you have to be able to find the
right mixture of elements and the right
conditions
but where could that be in the universe
of course one place we can be sure of is
right here the surface of the Earth a
planet with an abundance of water and a
thick but not too thick atmosphere for
our Earth sits in What's called the
habitable zone of the sun this is a
region around a star where the
temperature is just right closer to a
star and the intense heat and radiation
will boil away any water turning it into
a vapor too far away and that water
freezes into solid ice every Star has
its own habitable zone with the location
and size of that zone depending on the
nature of the star small dwarf stars
have habitable zones brushing right up
against their surfaces giant stars have
habitable zones reaching hundreds of
millions of miles away
the habitable zone of the sun begins
just within the orbit of Venus and
extends outwards just past the orbit of
Mars but of the three worlds within that
zone only the Earth maintains liquid
water in the present day and so we can
conclude from this small example that
the conditions for Life as We Know It
are very strict with Venus scientists
strongly suspect that it once had a
thinner atmosphere and supported oceans
on its surface but as the sun aged it
steadily grew brighter and hotter within
a few hundred million years the intense
heat from the Sun triggered a runaway
greenhouse effect on Venus evaporating
its oceans and building up a thick
atmosphere dominated by carbon dioxide
the conditions on the surface are now so
hellish that it's hot enough to melt
lead
Mars on the other hand was also once
much warmer had a much thicker
atmosphere and also had oceans rivers
lakes and streams
we see evidence for past water activity
everywhere we look on the surface today
but as verdant as Mars once was it was
also born with a fatal defect
it was too small
in less than a billion years it cooled
off its molten core turning solid
without a molten core its magnetic field
shut off without a magnetic field the
solar wind stripped the atmosphere away
the planet dried
and died
however Universe wide that is relatively
small scale even entire Galaxies have
their own habitable zones too close to
the core of a galaxy too many stars will
live and die flooding their neighbors
with deadly radiation and the outskirts
of a galaxy are too thin with heavier
elements preventing planets from forming
in the first place
[Music]
but to even have the chance for life to
appear in the habitable zone of a star
or Galaxy with liquid water rich with
Prebiotic organic compounds appearing on
the surface of a planet near a pleasant
star you first need organic compounds
and liquid water
indeed the origins of Earth's abundant
oceans remains a mystery certainly the
Earth formed with a lot of water in the
first place as it's the most common
element in the entire universe but most
of the water did not end up on the
surface it either got locked up as
chemical compounds in the mantle indeed
there's more water in the mantle than
anywhere else on Earth or evaporated
while our planet was still Molten
astronomers believe that comets and
asteroids are likely played an important
role in replenishing the water supply of
the earth
these small leftover bits of debris from
the formation of the planets generally
formed in the outer regions of the solar
system where water could survive as ice
then impact after impact on the young
Planet brought with it a fresh round of
water which eventually built up to
generate our oceans but again this
process had to be just right if the
Earth suffered too many impacts or too
large then it would have reheated our
surface turning it molten again and
sending us back to the start
and it's also possible that these early
impacts brought with them
something else
in 2014 the Japanese space agency
launched the Hayabusa 2 mission a probe
headed to the asteroid ryugo
that mission collected a sample from the
surface of ryugu and returned it to
Earth for closest study
back in the laboratory scientists were
amazed to discover the presence of
several amino acids in the dust grains
of the asteroid
including some that formed the basis of
Earthly life
and so it seems that the Miller Yuri
experiment is just one of many options
available for the universe to make
organic compounds and more complex amino
acids scientists aren't sure how these
molecules were created on ryugo but it
likely involved some complex interaction
with the sun's ultraviolet radiation
which could have provided the energy
needed to turn simple compounds into
amino acids
considering that ryugu is a Remnant from
the formation of the solar system and
has remained untouched for over 4
billion years the timeline would fit for
the early arrival of life's building
blocks to the Earth's surface
but the presence of amino acids goes
back even further than rocks in our
solar system
[Music]
in 2003 a team of astronomers found
evidence for glycine the simplest of the
amino acids in several giant molecular
clouds these clouds are the places in
galaxies where stars and solar systems
form so it's also possible that amino
acids could have been carried along with
the formation of the Earth from the very
beginning
astronomers have also spotted a variety
of organic compounds in giant molecular
clouds throughout the Galaxy in other
galaxies and even distant quasars
these quasars only appear in the young
universe suggesting that the basic
chemistry for life has been present for
a very long time
but even that is not the true beginning
all that chemistry has to come
from somewhere
[Music]
molecules assemble themselves from
elements in a variety of processes
throughout the Universe and almost all
the elements on the periodic table come
from a process known as stellar
nucleosynthesis
this process was discovered in 1957 in a
landmark paper authored by the husband
and wife team of Jeffrey and Margaret
Burbidge along with William Fowler and
Fred Hoyle in their work they provided a
detailed and complete description of how
Stars fashion elements
the key is nuclear fusion our sun is
currently fusing hydrogen into helium to
generate heat near the end of its life
it will turn to fusing helium producing
carbon and oxygen in the process when it
dies it will spread these elements out
where they will join the general mix of
the interstellar medium stars much
heavier than the sun are capable of
fusing carbon and oxygen into potassium
magnesium and more all the elements up
to and including iron
to generate even heavier elements the
universe has to turn to more energetic
processes
supernovae carry enough energy to fuse
many heavy elements but it turns out
that merging neutron stars carry just
the right combination of energy duration
and sheer number of neutrons to produce
many more including gold and silver
and so to generate Life as we know it we
not only need the right conditions the
right chemicals water and a temperate
Planet but most fundamentally
we need Stars
multiple generations of stars to be
exact all fusing elements dying in
Supernova bursts and merging together to
fill out the periodic table
only after a galaxy has generated
sufficient quantities of the basics like
carbon and oxygen can water and solid
rock form providing enough material to
build planets with the required organic
chemistry
but stars have not always been present
in the universe the Big Bang only
produced hydrogen helium and the
scattering of lithium and beryllium and
there were hundreds of millions of years
before the first Stars ignited
so on our journey to find the earliest
possible moment that life could have
Arisen we will need to reach back into
the darkest ages of the universe
imagine years in the future we finally
uncover what dark matter really is
after Decades of effort and struggle it
turns out to be quite simple the vast
majority of the mass of our universe is
revealed to be made of some new particle
that had previously been unknown to
physics
some slight adjustments to the standard
model and a series of confirmed direct
detections later the mystery is
conclusively solved a single particle
that participates in the gravitational
interaction and very rarely through the
weak nuclear force
and that is it
Laboratories are shut down proposals for
New Missions scrapped without a grand
mystery to ignite passion and curiosity
funding dries up and astronomers and
physicists go on to study other Cosmic
questions
but a small team of scientists persist
in their experiments and observations
unconvinced by the accepted explanation
while the new standard model explains
the vast majority of Dark Matter
phenomena there are still some holes for
example these new dark matter particles
can very rarely interact with each other
annihilating in a burst of light a flash
of gamma-ray radiation for decades we
had observed an excessive amount of
gamma rays coming from the center of the
Milky Way but long assumed it was due to
some particle physics interactions not
dark matter
but this final team working on Dark
Matter thinks there is more scraping
together funding they develop a
high-resolution gamma-ray telescope
aiming squarely at the center of the
Milky Way the gamma-ray signal is there
just as expected a product of the Dark
Matter particles annihilating
but the more the researchers study the
signal the more questions they have
for the signal isn't perfectly steady
but is constantly changing ever so
slightly
the scientists dream up and discard a
dozen theories to explain the variation
nothing works after years of study the
funding runs out the team disbands
frustrated at their lack of progress
[Music]
but years later on a sleepless night one
of the former graduate students in the
group pulls up the old data
acting on a hunch she processes the
signal variations in a slightly
different way
and then she sees it
every few seconds the gamma-ray signal
changes in intensity by a precise amount
sometimes the signal increases in
intensity and sometimes it drops the
time between shifts however never
changes and the up down pattern never
repeats except after over a month has
passed
then the same Rhythm appears again and
again
and again
marking an increase in intensity is a
one and a decrease in intensity as a
zero the former student begins
scribbling on a nearby piece of scrap
paper
[Music]
one one zero zero zero one one one
zero zero zero zero one one zero zero
our quest to find the earliest possible
appearance of life in the universe has
taken us to the breaking of the cosmic
Dawn
and the birth of the first Stars
those first Stars fused only hydrogen
and could have been as large as hundreds
or thousands of suns they were born they
lived Furious but brief lives and they
died beginning the cosmic recycling of
the elements each generation of stars to
come after adding to the enrichment of
the interstellar medium eventually after
an unknown number of generations a solar
system could form a star orbited by
enough Rocky and icy material to Fashion
planets out of the chaos
[Music]
we know that the first Stars didn't
appear until at least 100 million years
after the big bang we also know based on
observations with the James Webb Space
Telescope and more that galaxies
appeared to be fully constructed within
500 million years there was a time
before that when our universe was 10 to
15 million years old that the cosmic
microwave background flooded the
universe with room temperature radiation
but that was well before the development
of rocky planets or even water and so
while we don't yet have a precise answer
we do have limits
the first possibility for Life as We
Know It swimming in liquid water oceans
on a rocky planet orbiting a Placid star
would have occurred somewhere between
100 and 500 million years after the big
bang our own solar system formed some 9
billion years later and so it is safe to
assume the Earth was not the first
opportunity for our universe to create
life
but of course that's only accounting for
the kind of life that we conclusively
know of
not the kinds of life that we can
imagine
[Music]
let's return to our simple definition of
life that which is subject to darwinian
evolution
this requires information storage
self-replication and the ability to
interact with the environment life on
Earth accomplished this with a soup of
chemicals immersed in water with deep
sea vents or sunlight providing an ample
source of energy to drive chemical
reactions
and so the earliest life that looks
similar to this could not exist for at
least a few hundred million years well
after a few generations of stars had
already come and gone but scientists
have speculated about many Alternative
forms of biochemistry besides Methane
biochemists have also proposed ammonia
hydrogen fluoride hydrogen sulfide and
silicon dioxide as alternatives to water
others have proposed that arsenic which
is deadly to almost all life on Earth
might be a useful substitute for
phosphorus on some exotic world or that
silicon while not as robust and sturdy
as carbon might provide a suitable
foundation for complex molecular chains
that could lead to intricate living
systems indeed in 2007 physicist Vadim
and sidovich ran computer simulations of
molecular interactions and found that
Dusty grains in interstellar gas clouds
when suspended in an energetic plasma
could begin to self-organize and form
complex shape
certainly not life itself but the
Intriguing hint that something like life
could arise
though whether it's the surface of a
planet deep under a crust or miles of
atmosphere or tucked away in some
Interstellar gas cloud all these
Alternatives ultimately require the same
thing chemistry
the elements of the periodic table have
to exist in the first place before they
can begin mixing together in interesting
ways that can potentially lead to life
and so these Alternatives cannot push
the emergence of the first life in the
universe back much before the kinds we
would recognize on Earth
[Music]
to go further back we have to get more
exotic
[Music]
in 1973 eminent physicist Frank Drake
proposed that microscopic structures
inside neutron stars could meet all the
conditions for darwinian evolution these
structures would be bound by the strong
nuclear force and could form complex
interacting shapes surrounded by the
Abundant energy of the neutron star's
own heat these structures could
potentially begin the path to
self-replication but of course to create
neutron stars the universe first has to
create Stars
and so this possibility pushes back the
potential for life to just after the
very first generation of stars some 100
million years after the big bang
another hypothesis proposed by Louis a
andradoki and Eugene M chodnovsky of the
City University of New York states that
life composed of magnetic monopoles
connected by cosmic strings could take
on complex forms however physicists
continue to debate the very existence of
magnetic monopoles and cosmic strings
and this idea requires that these exotic
compounds exist in a heat bath namely
that they are embedded inside Stars so
that still doesn't push the clock back
any further
but there is another possibility hidden
in the Dark Sector of the universe
all of our understanding of physics from
the table of elements to the fundamental
particles comprises less than five
percent of all the energy and mass in
the entire universe most of the cosmos
is of a form unknown to Modern physics
this unknown is divided into two sectors
dark matter which makes up the mass of
most galaxies and dark energy which is
responsible for the accelerated
expansion of the universe
despite this categorization scheme we
still don't understand the natures of
dark matter and dark energy
they could very well be simple a
particle that interacts with nothing
except through gravity and a Quantum
force that pervades space-time
or they can be more complex
new forces of nature could allow Dark
Matter to interact with itself and with
dark energy there could be multiple
species of Dark Matter particles
entirely new interactions could take
place among these particles allowing
them to form their own Periodic Table of
dark elements
dark atoms dark molecules dark chemistry
dark life
a completely alien form of life using
sources of energy beyond our
understanding existing in the Hidden
Shadows of the universe that life could
be at play right now even in the present
day Cosmos completely unobservable to us
and if that kind of dark shadow life is
possible it could have emerged well
before the first stars as it had access
to sources of energy Beyond Simple
nuclear fusion perhaps Stark life
appeared while the universe was still in
its plasma state
and that is not the end of it
[Music]
simply put we do not understand the
conditions of the extremely early
universe
the energies at play when our Cosmos was
less than a second old are far beyond
our current level of understanding
who knows what exotic forces danced in
the fires of the Big Bang
who knows what structures and patterns
emerged something like life could very
well have Arisen in that Maelstrom
creating living and maybe even thinking
Untold Generations passing from one to
the next unknown and unknowable to us in
their cold and distant future a legacy
erased by the inevitable expansion and
cooling of the cosmos
emerged and extinct in less than the
blink of an eye
but even considering all of these
remarkable possibilities if ancient life
did arise
how could we ever know
during a pleasant afternoon in the
summer of 1950 famed particle physics
Pioneer in Rico Fermi was walking to
lunch with his colleagues
as is usually the case when physicists
take a break from work they started
speculating in this case around the
topic of aliens
after debating back and forth for a
while on the possibility of
extraterrestrial life and the likelihood
of encountering it the conversation
eventually moved on
but the question must have dogged in
Rico because later that lunch apropos of
nothing he suddenly blurted out
where is everybody
the train of logic is simple the Earth
is not particularly special yes there's
liquid water on the surface a clement
environment a rich soup of organic
materials an abundant and steady supply
of energy we have no evidence of these
conditions let alone life arising
anywhere else in the solar system let
alone the Galaxy
and yet the universe is vast
there are at least a hundred billion
stars currently alive in the Milky Way
galaxy there are potentially almost 2
trillion galaxies within the observable
volume of the universe and in physics
nothing happens just once either nature
forbids it and it never happens or it
allows it and the universe is large
enough to accommodate multiple instances
of even the rarest phenomenon for
example modern estimates suggest that
the Milky Way alone hosts around 5
billion Earth-like planets in the
habitable zones of sun-like stars
and that's just one Galaxy
[Music]
and so Earth is special and life is rare
but Earth isn't that special and we have
no reason to believe life is that rare
we are just one rocky planet orbiting
one unremarkable star
if life happened here then logic
dictates it must be a somewhat generic
feature of the universe and so it must
have happened elsewhere
and to add to this the universe isn't
just gigantic
it is ancient
Earth-like life could have Arisen as
early as 100 million years after the big
bang the cosmos is now almost 400 times
as old life appeared on the earth as
soon as the crust cooled and oceans
formed almost 4 billion years ago and so
by now almost 14 billion years after the
big bang and 9 billion years after the
formation of the Milky Way countless
alien life forms should have Arisen
crawled out of their oceans survived
terrible catastrophes evolved to
intelligence developed a sophisticated
civilization and invented the Necessary
Technology to travel Among the Stars
even we humans have managed to send a
spacecraft beyond the bounds of the
solar system and out into Interstellar
space and we have been trying for less
than a century
Enrico argued that the Galaxy should be
littered with the debris of alien
civilizations come and gone there should
be active probes in the solar system
remnants of Technology everywhere we
look logically we should have evolved in
the plains of Africa with full awareness
of the aliens watching us even guiding
us
and yet
nothing
no sign of intelligence let alone life
anywhere else in the galaxy
this is fermi's famous paradox
life should be everywhere but instead we
are forced to ask
where is everybody
[Music]
answering this Paradox forces us to
tackle the same challenging question
again how would we recognize
extraterrestrial life
the most exotic forms of life imaginable
like creatures living in the first
instant of the Big Bang or within the
Dark Sector of the universe would likely
remain elusive to us forever with any
evidence of their existence hidden from
even our most clever experiments
but Earth-like life or even life based
on exotic chemical combinations that is
a different story
one answer is to focus solely on
intelligent life as the thinking goes
that while intelligent civilizations May
tend to be rarer than generic simple
life they are at least loud as soon as
humans developed radio technology for
example we started blasting signals
around the world and out into space
this is the backbone of seti the surge
for extraterrestrial intelligence the
general seti program searches for radio
signals produced by artificial means
radio is especially handy because it's
easy to generate in large quantities
with relatively little power and it can
sail through thousands of light years of
Interstellar dust clouds without getting
itself scattered or absorbed
unfortunately after Decades of scanning
the radio skies for any signs of
intelligence we've found nothing
one possibility of course is that we
have only barely scratched the possible
search space after all astronomical
observations are difficult and expensive
especially when they are across a broad
range of frequencies across the entire
sky and as often as possible
so we may have simply missed the few
stray artificial radio signals that have
washed over the Earth in the past half
century
but other seti attempts have also failed
alternative directions are focused on
searching for physical artifacts of
intelligent civilizations like
alterations of Stellar chemistry as a
signal to the wider universe or the
construction of Mega engineering
projects like Dyson spheres but no known
Stars show signs of artificial pollution
and no Dyson spheres appear in our scans
across the Galaxy and out into the wider
universe
besides these searches for intelligence
hunts for any forms of life have also
come up empty despite our trying every
possible angle
the alien worlds orbiting within the
habitable zones of Their Stars we've
studied the light filtering through
their atmospheres looking for
biosignatures like excess oxygen and
methane something that could not
possibly have a purely chemical origin
no matter how exotic
and while many of these searches are
still nascent the ones we have performed
have still come up empty
we found thousands of exoplanets and
many potentially habitable worlds like
the trappist-1 system or Proxima B and
many with thick atmospheres
and yet in all that work we haven't
found a single shred of evidence for
life outside the Earth
and so where is everybody
the first possibility to consider is
that fermi's base assumption is wrong
that life truly is rare
the Earth and our conditions being
special if not entirely unique within
the Galaxy that you could have a
thousand a million a billion copies of
Earth all with the exact same
temperatures and pressures and soup of
chemicals and life would only appear on
one of them
or perhaps while life may be common
intelligent life is not
perhaps there are microbes on almost
every wet world in the Galaxy but that
in 14 billion years of cosmic history we
are the first intelligent civilization
to arise in the Milky Way to beat the
astronomical odds stacked against us and
look into the universe with curious
minds that we for all intents and
purposes save for some microscopic
cousins that we might encounter in our
Explorations in the distant future
ah alone
life could have been right in front of
our eyes from the start but of a
chemical form that we cannot yet
distinguish from non-life perhaps
creatures really did once crawl through
that Martian meteorite perhaps the
buried Seas of the outer moons are alive
and active but we may not yet realize it
for what it is
and of course yet another possibility is
that both life and intelligence are
common
but not for long
[Music]
life may gain foothold after foothold on
countless worlds only to be snuffed out
just looking at her own geologic history
illustrates the risks that being alive
brings how many times was the earth
almost wiped clean and that even before
the rise of sentience once intelligence
arose we developed the capability to
destroy ourselves relatively quickly but
perhaps still lack the sophistication to
assure her own Survival
proliferation of nuclear weapons and the
spiraling disaster of climate change may
not threaten us as a species but it
could certainly spell Doom for our
ability to communicate with the wider
Cosmos could we possibly recover our
technological might from such a
catastrophe or would we Linger on for
Generations returning to the ways of our
ancient ancestors until some larger
Calamity consumes us
but let us put that to one side and
imagine we prevail
perhaps we do spread throughout the
solar system and even the local Galaxy
overcoming the vast distances that
separate the Stars perhaps we endure for
a million years or more an unimaginable
amount of time to remain technologically
sophisticated
the problem is that is almost nothing on
a cosmic scale
the universe is 13.8 billion years old
our home Galaxy one of trillions
eventually some limit is reached and we
simply dwindle away with nothing more
than empty worlds and dead space probes
to call our Legacy
and so maybe we're not alone that in 14
billion years and among two trillion
galaxies other intelligent species have
Arisen and even spread but the vast
expanse of time and space that dominate
the universe cruelly separates us from
any meaningful sustained contact our
loudest radio blasts mere Whispers in
the background our brightest beacons
only flickers of dim candlelights
but perhaps just perhaps our deep
descendants Generations from now will
explore our galaxy and find it filled
with the graveyards of extinct
civilizations
what monuments will they find buried
under miles of dirt on some alien world
what probes might they encounter in the
depths of the interstellar void
such a discovery would answer many
questions and raise even more it would
be a clue not just to the origins of
humanity but to the origins of all life
in the universe
what alien Gobekli Tepe sits out there
waiting for us to find it
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
foreign